رغم القذف المتكرر على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف الى ان العديد من سكان هذه المدينه
اصروا للخروج من اجل مشاهده المباراه
النهائيه لكاس العالم انقسم بين من يشجع
المنتخب الفرنسي وبين عشاق ليونيل ميسي
لذلك تفاعلوا كثيرا مع الفرص التي خلقها
المنتخب الارجنتيني زاهليه انا اشجع
المنتخب الفرنسي لكنني سافرح ايضا اذا فاز
ميسي بالكاس انه يستحققها علينا ان نخرج
هو احيانا ونرى ما يحدث من حولنا لاننا
اذا لم نفعل ذلك سينفجر جهازنا العصبي
ويمكن ان نجن ايضا لابد ان نعرف كيف نقتنم
اللحظات السعيده
اوكراني عدم منذ ايام من جبهه القتال
تحدث الان
من اجل الصمود امام القوات الروسيه
اشعر بسعاده كبيره انا الان بين عائلتي
واصدقائي واخوتي في السلاح شعوري لا يوصف
انا فخور ببلد بصمودها وبالطريقه التي
تحارب بها العدو على روسيا ان تدرك ان
اوكرانيا ستنتصر اخيرا
فرحه كبيره صنعها الانصاري
بعد نهايه المباراه